we are very saddened to learn of the  death of his royal highness the duke of  edinburgh  the duke has served our country for  almost 70 years  and has a special place in the hearts of  the district and the nation  and the close affinity with devon  through his links with the naval college  and his support for programs such as ten  tours our sincere condolences to the  royal family  at this sad time and our thoughts are  with them  and although suffering this loss we have  lowered our flag  on the ford house office to half mast as  a mark of respect  regrettably we are unable to offer a  book and condolence  for people to sign in person but we  would encourage anyone who wishes to do  so  to sign the official palace online  condolence ebook